así suena la esperanza por una nueva
vida 6500 migrantes es el número de la
última de las caravanas centroamericanas
que se dirige hacia eeuu según las
autoridades migratorias guatemaltecas
más de tres mil habrían conseguido
cruzar la frontera desde honduras
centenares habrían sido detenidos entre
los que hay familias con niños una
situación de desesperación que superan
las autoridades fronterizas
incluso llevándolas al despliegue de
militares ya la solicitud de pruebas
negativas para cambiar de país
los huracanes yo está a dieta han dejado
a miles de personas sin hogar ni
subsistencia a esta catástrofe se le
suma el golpe que está suponiendo la
pandemia de kobe 19 para la economía de
los países centroamericanos problemas
que se añaden a la violencia sistémica
de la región tras guatemala méjico y
después el destino final estados unidos
con la ilusión por la elección como
presidente de joe biden le pedimos que
él
se llenó de misericordia que dios le
toque su corazón y que abra puertas sólo
queremos una oportunidad para trabajar
los migrantes confían en un cambio de
políticas migratorias respecto a la
dureza de donald trump by den en una
llamada en diciembre con el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
coincidió en la necesidad de una nueva
estrategia migratoria una esperanza que
sólo el tiempo confirmará si revierte la
desesperación de los migrantes
centroamericanos o bien si por el
contrario continúan surgiendo nuevas
caravanas